all right the dallas cowboys make news
even when they don't have
an outbreak or a contract problem or
really anything else they had a
an exciting game on sunday against the
other game now the reason he was even in
a position to throw the interception
is because he ran away from pressure
avoided falling down if he would have
fallen down is because he ran away from
pressure avoided falling down if he
would have fallen down the clock likely
would have run out
by the time the receivers got back from
the end zone and they snapped the ball
for what would have been like fourth and
28
but uh that issue of quarterback
mobility came up during
one of jerry jones two radio appearances
per week on 105.3 the fan in dallas
and his comments created a little bit of
a stir
on the question of whether or not jerry
jones was comparing
dak in an unfavorable way to other
mobile quarterbacks let's listen
to jerry jones from earlier today
and obviously with their quarterback
who's
i think at the highest
level right now because of his
frankly as much as just his
natural ability to make plays his
mobility
and this guy's very uh
quick and elusive and can get in and out
of situations with his feet and by
time the quarterback we played sunday
is of that kind of nature that has great
ability to get in and out
and then make the play that played dak
made at the end of the game that got
intercepted
well uh the result of dax ability that
let him get that ball off
was really great and outstanding
well these guys have that ability a lot
they are very quick footed and they're
very
they have the unique ability to possibly
take their eyes
away from the field for a minute and
then immediately focus
back and see romo had that
and so they could turn his back on it
and turn around and
hand-dye and get it done quick and so
those are things that show up and that's
what's showing up with these guys
they're buying time with their feet
for buying time with their instincts and
their feet
you know when i saw the comments written
i thought there was no criticism of dak
prescott when i heard it
i feel a little bit differently now
there is a little bit
of a backhand at dak because
he bought time with his feet but
he threw the ball into like five guys it
was the throw he shouldn't have made in
hindsight
in hindsight what he should have done
and maybe what patrick mahomes or
russell wilson two of the quarterbacks
that jerry jones was talking about
would have done get out of bounds right
he had the opportunity to gain
six seven eight yards make it a shorter
throw to the end zone you got one play
after that
there would have been time left on the
clock instead of reacting to that oh
crap moment i almost fell down and the
clock would have run out
by just unloading the ball into the end
zone when he shouldn't have
maybe there's an argument to be made a
little sliver of an argument that what
he's saying is
yes dak has the mobility but what he
doesn't have and that wilson mahomes and
romo
do have is the opportunity to make a
good decision
after they use their mobility to extend
the play
mike i've gotten three phone calls today
from my former co-worker and our good
friend clarence hill who kind of started
this whole stroke
and knows jerry as well as anyone knows
him and he reads it as jerry's criticism
of and we should say that the question
was
do you feel like there's a big gap
between you
and the kansas city chiefs after
watching the chiefs last night there was
no mention
of patrick mahomes there was no mention
of russell wilson jerry jones brought
those
up on his own the problem with this is
we all have to interpret jury we call
them jerry isms and you have to
interpret what he says
sometimes you're right and sometimes
you're wrong
but the problem is that the reporters
are not getting
jerry after games they're not getting
them in the week
after practice on a normal season
there would be a follow-up you would get
to at least at minimum ask
jerry after next week's game if not this
week during the week
what he meant by that comment was it
criticism
of dak prescott and he likely is going
to say no it was not it was not
intended that way but at least you would
have the opportunity to get
to him and ask him that question and no
telling what he says as we know jerry
could say anything
once you get him so that's been a big
problem i think with this
is no one's going to follow up in this
and say
what did you really mean by this was it
meant as a criticism
of dak prescott and we don't know i mean
we're just trying to interpret what
jerry said and
there may be a little bit in there there
may not be maybe it's a contract thing
we know that he's playing under the
franchise tag they're gonna have to get
back to the negotiating table after the
season
again reading the words that were posted
in an item at 105.3 the fan the same
words we just heard it gave me a
different feeling
hearing it a different vibe and here's
the reality he's on 105 3 the fan twice
per week but he's on different shows
between tuesday and friday
the friday hosts may feel no compulsion
to come back
to that point maybe they will maybe they
won't and
by the time the tuesday hosts have him
again there will have been another game
played there'll be other things to talk
about you got a lot of business you want
to take care of with jerry jones
and because he gives you really long
answers you go
into the interview load it up with
questions
and maybe you get to ask five of them so
as a practical matter this may fall
through the cracks and
look also would it be a surprise if
because of the blowback somebody from
the cowboys says to their flagship
station don't revisit that issue
with dak and mobility and mahomes and
wilson let's just let that one die
no they would never do that
i detect a small amount of sarcasm
sarcasm or sarcasm coming from shireen
on that
uh anyway i you know what here's what i
have to do i'm sitting here thinking
crap i spent a half hour writing a story
about this saying he wasn't criticizing
dak now i gotta go back and write a
story tonight add this video hello to
anyone who's reading the story and
clicked on the video if you made it this
far thank you
and explain you know what maybe he was
and maybe there is a broader
play going on here as it relates to the
fact that if they apply the franchise
tag to him next year
it's 37.68 million dollars and maybe
they won't i had someone tell me that
back in june
don't assume they're going to apply the
franchise tag next year i said baloney
they applied the highest possible level
this year why would they not apply it
next year they're just going to let them
walk away as a free agent
who are they going to replace him with i
don't think that's going to happen so
either way
he's still going to be the quarterback
and the reality is guys who can
extend the play with their legs shireen
and have the presence of mind to make a
great decision with the football
after they've extended the play with
their legs there aren't many guys who
can do
that no they're not and they're
not many deck prescotts i mean jerry
remembers what happened between troy
aikman
and tony romo and it was not pretty and
he finally found tony romo and now
they've made this seamless transition
into dak prescott so
they're not going to let that pre dak
prescott get away they're going to keep
him and
and they'll end up paying him and
they're going to end up paying him way
more than
they wanted to pay him and way more than
they should have paid him if they had
signed him
when they should have signed him which
was a long long long time ago
but they'll they'll keep dak prescott
he'll be their quarterback and on the
play
that dak made he was asked about it
after the game and he said an
interception never entered his mind like
he was throwing that ball to try to get
a completion obviously a touchdown but
he thought the worst case scenario
was an incompletion but as you saw in
the video i mean it's there's
seahawks everywhere they played it like
a hail mary as they should and
ended up getting the pick and end of the
game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports